because now as an adult i'm mentally and
emotionally broken
and coming back from that type of
lifestyle isn't easy at all
most girls don't well they they kind of
got a saying for it once a whole always
a hoe
can't turn the hole into a housewife
all right devin devin where'd you grow
up where are you from originally
i am from washington washington state
yes and tell me about your childhood you
had both your parents growing up
um i did have both my parents when i was
very very small
around three a lot started to change
um mom dealt with a lot of big drug
dealers
and she eventually got into the drug
life by herself
so dad kind of got tired of it because
now it's going from
money to use and he kind of bailed out
on us a couple times came back
the last time that we had seen our
father um
was around a christmas and my mom was
having a baby
she was really really sick her appendix
was gonna burst
so they said that it would be my mom or
the baby it couldn't be both
my real mom passed away and my dad wound
up in prison
so we kind of had a rough
start to life it's been really really
hard not having my parents
so i tell a lot of the kids nowadays you
need to take
having parents a parent any parent in
your life as a royalty
because to some of us we want that
really really bad because maybe like i
think maybe i wouldn't have turned out
how it turned out
maybe i would have took a different path
i might have been a little bit better
how old are you i'm 25.
so life with your grandmother how was
that
um you know it was fun we were very
disciplined
so i do come from a good home you know
we came from a great setting
it was just hard being a good kid
because we didn't go to the best schools
um we went to a lot of the schools that
you would locate somewhere in the hood
um is it seattle um by this time we had
already moved out to california
we got settled in and you know
old women aren't like the ones that you
really got to look at like okay
i role model and so it was hard she was
strict she kind of taught us like this
if we were born in like the 70s or
something
which made it even more fun for us
because that was something for us to
talk about oh remember when you got that
whooping
and you know you you did this you did
that
like that'd be the cases where grandma
would come and she said pick a switch
and i'm looking at my grandma like
uh what'd you just say
like um we weren't born in the 70s i
think you guys have something called
belts and stuff now
um it was really really good learning
from somebody that old made me real
really really whismatic today and um
for the most part it's it was a good
childhood
but my grandma eventually got tired and
she said she couldn't do it anymore so
we went to the foster system
and that's when things really got rough
it became hard for me to cope with the
simple thought of not having my parents
anymore
mom being passed away and dad being in
penitentiary and knowing that he doesn't
have a chance at parole
um and the simple fact that now my
grandma's giving up on us
it put me in this place where i felt
like
okay i had to go find some type of love
and i didn't stay in any of my foster
homes because of that i felt like okay
if my grandma doesn't want me and that's
my family
then why would anybody else want me i
started to feel ugly
and then pretty i started dressing like
a boy
started talking to other girls i stopped
caring
started gang-banging and and running the
streets and not coming home till
two three o'clock in the morning and it
was really hard for me
i mean i there's six of us all together
so
having my brothers and my sisters two
younger siblings and then the older ones
was like
i can't look up to my brothers my
sisters because i'm the darkest one in
the family
everybody else is like high yellow and
it was like you know i was always
getting bullied oh
you came from the milkman and we found
you behind the dumpster
and you were adopted that's why nobody
likes you and
so i had a good childhood but it was
really rough it was hard growing up
because you know there's at times oh yo
mama
yo mama there were things that i took
to heart a lot that really touched me
emotionally so a lot of kids didn't mess
with me because
i was like really sensitive i'm still
really sensitive
um the yo mama jokes and stuff it all
put me in this place where i feel like
okay
instead of being weenie and being soft
i'm gonna be
okay you guys want hard people i'm gonna
be hard i'm gonna be a gang member i'm
gonna be this and i kind of switched up
from like
that quiet in the corner kid that played
the clarinet
to okay now she's kind of blossoming
i started playing basketball i started
hanging out with the little
um what do you guys call my clicks and
i started getting in trouble i
eventually landed myself at juvenile
hall
um for fighting it went from fighting to
assault on a police officer
from assaults on a police officer to
shootings
and it just kept advancing and i didn't
catch it till i was like 16 years old
they were like um you know with the
right you're going you're gonna wind up
in the penitentiary
you're gonna have a life sentence
believe it or not or you're gonna wind
up dead somewhere
oh okay it doesn't mind me none i get
out of juvenile hall around
what's your dad in prison for um he's
the drug dealer
um my father's name is fat cat um he's
been in jail for
as long as i can remember i think i was
like
three or four the last time i seen my
dad
um i haven't really thought too much
about him lately
because i mean i don't really know him
i know him to the point where i know
that i could look him up and find him
and write him
and you know maybe have a good letter or
two back and forth
i don't think i would take the chance to
go see him
and i really don't respect people
that go off on killing other people just
because
just because a simple thought and
jumping gun
isn't my thing and by the stories that
i've read about him and stuff he's a
i jumped the gun type of guy so so he's
in for murder um
murder drug dealing um
soliciting women i mean all types of
thing he was a really big drug lord
back in the day and it didn't land him
in the proper spot
i think about it when i was growing up
like okay maybe if i be like him
i'll get away with it i wind up doing
all that same exact stuff
so can't really talk about him too much
yeah
all right so back back to your story i'm
sorry um
when i was like 16 i went to
y.a for assaults on a police officer and
attempted murder with a deadly weapon
um that kind of was my slap in the face
with reality like hey look straighten up
um at that time i was pregnant with my
first daughter i got out instantly when
i got out i'm like okay
everybody goes to that phase where
they're like okay now i'm at this age
and i have
these you know these hormones that are
running right now
and i'm going to go get my issue and at
16 i was like okay
now i see more where the girls are
coming from where they say okay you need
money to do and
do because i wanted to go party i wanted
to be part of the crew
um i got out started messing with this
guy
stopped talking to him because he had a
abuse problem
and ever since i was little it's been
like abuse emotional
sexual physical i i don't want that i
didn't want that so i stopped talking to
him
i ran back into a boy that i met when i
was 13.
they called him tz tz lee the pimp
and um me and tz were real tight
that was like my best friend in the
whole world i would do anything for him
including selling my body i did every
and anything
i could for him when i was with him he's
actually the father of my kids
um lately we have not
had the best relationship
but i still try so that my daughters
don't have to be like me
always having the feeling like okay i
was somebody's burden and they didn't
want me
and that's really really a bad feeling
to have growing up as a woman
it's it makes you feel like you don't
need to care about yourself sometimes
and it bothers me till now it's kind of
like
okay i depend i co-depend on this guy to
be there for me because that's what i
feel like love is
even though knowing in the back of my
head with experience
that's not what love is i went to ya for
shooting at a cop
um that record
fortunately got dropped so i don't have
a record at all
because that same cop that i went to
jail for shooting at
went to jail for shooting at somebody
else off duty with his on duty gun his
wife was seen at a hampton
with another man she was a model and he
winded up shooting at the guy
in the elevator so he went to jail of
course and no cop
no show um the judge looked it in she
said you know you're young
i want to see what you can do if you
could progress by yourself
she let me out on probation um
finished my probation got back in school
got my high school diploma
um kind of just like started to
straighten out because i realized
at that point that
being a gang member shooting at police
didn't make me hard
it just [ __ ] up my record
or screwed up my record it wasn't the
you know it wasn't the excitement that i
was looking for
a lot of things people do especially
people in the street life
they do things because of the thrill
that they get out of it
and the thrill wasn't there anymore it
was like okay
i'm a little bit past the age where
everything that i do outside in the
streets excites me it stopped exciting
me
i got to the point where i was like okay
bills
i'm 18 now and i have bills
and that's when the prostitution really
picked up heavy
um i started doing little dates you know
i'm more of a of a image person
so in my head i wanted to get out of the
streets so i started going to the clubs
um stripping but
it still didn't make anything better
pocket wise you know my i got a little
bit more money than you would in the
streets
um you're not seen as much so that's
what i was thinking of
is be more so hidden because
being a prostitute or or um
a diva whatever you would like to call
it you know you're getting money from a
from another person for soliciting your
body
it doesn't make you feel beautiful so
the more discreet you can be about it
the
less people have to see you the better
you'll feel about it
um i just kind of started
to feel like okay i feel a little
worthless
then the guys they don't talk to you
like as if you're a regular woman you
see the way that they treat these girls
that they're
they're taking your money to go spend on
these other women and it's like
why do you treat her this way and i'm
getting treated a whole completely
opposite different way you know it's
it's i in our heads i would think that
you'd respect it as
at least a little bit a tad because i'm
getting out there and i'm selling my
body not just for me but
for you my money takes care of you too
and half the time we're not getting out
of it i mean
most of us sometimes they the guys want
to do it this way give you two
cigarettes
here's two secrets out of your whole
entire box and you just paid for it
here's uh five dollars okay what is an
emergency what if i get taken to a place
where i can't come back from
and i have no money to my name they so
we we work really hard
we bust our ass we sell ourselves short
have no respect for ourselves to get a
little bit of nothing
you're talking about a relationship with
a pimp yeah um
and most times the the pimps don't make
relationships with the girls
if it is like that then they were
probably like high school lovers
in like my case we started talking when
we were younger
and it just kind of went advanced first
he was just my friend
i didn't really like paying too much
attention it was high and byes and
okay you know that guy over there that's
who's that
and when we turned 18 we like really
started a talk talk
he said okay and everybody starts saying
you know he's pimp
like no you guys know there's no way
he's pimped oh yeah
tz is a pimp because you know he was
that boy in high school that had the
truck
and you know every girl wanted the boy
in high school that had the truck
because that just made you the it
of school and it went from the it to the
thing you know since he's a pimp he does
this certain things like putting hands
on you
on you and and taking your money and
going and doing what he wants to with
other women
and you don't realize that they do that
because they're pimps like and know him
gonna have just one female at all
and it was hard for me to think like
that so i'm at the point now that
i don't want to pimp i don't
really want to prostitute anymore i
don't do it too much
not as much as i used to because i
started to look at it like
i have to respect myself because i do
have two daughters now
and seeing how they look at me
it's just it's amazing being a mom is
amazing
and seeing the faces that they make with
certain things that happen throughout
the day is like wow you never realize
how weird you are
or how outgoing or or smart you are
until you have little use looking at you
doing the same exact stuff like wow i'm
weird as hell
these little me's are just they're doing
some weird stuff right now and
seeing your little yous and knowing okay
they did this but i know i did that
yesterday
it shows how much they learn from you
and i don't want my girls
to grow up in the life being prostitutes
or thinking that
a man putting hands on you or or taking
money from you because you're a
prostitute
is the way to live because it's not um
those are your daughters
i have a two-year-old three-year-old and
it this life has literally tore me it's
broke me
and i've looked in the mirror a lot of
times like damn i wonder who i could
have been
if i didn't live life i wonder who i
would have been
if i would never met that certain guy
and it hurts a lot of days it's like i
can't look in the mirror honestly and be
like oh you're beautiful
i can't look in the mirror and say i'm
in love with myself
because a lot of days i'm not a lot of
days i hate myself
um and it's hard to tell myself that i'm
beautiful
when a man can't respect you it's kind
of like
knowing your own husband or your own
boyfriend or kid's dad says that you're
ugly
it takes a major toll because selling
our bodies
puts us in a place where we don't feel
beautiful where some days we get up and
we
look at the ceiling like damn i don't
want to get up
because here goes another day of having
to sell myself short
for a little bit of nothing like in my
case right now
i'm struggling with homelessness my
kid's dad
he went to jail and
he got out and he just seemed like he
changed
he just stopped caring and
it put me in a hard spot going on my
second daughter because
now where i thank you
we're at a point where
i've got this daughter and i'm pregnant
with my second daughter
you know i'm barely pushing 19 and
i'm going to work i'm trying to
straighten my life out but dad wants to
go and hang out and party he wants to be
taking trips to vegas with these guys
that he met
and you know doing business deals and
just doing whatever he wants because
he's a guy and he feels like he could do
that because he's a guy
to i'm taking the girls to work and i'm
stressed out
i'm stressed out i'm about to blow i
mean i don't know what to do my belly is
so far over my stomach i can't see my
toes
what do i do lord please help me i wind
up losing the house i you know i make
pretty good money
it's not like not all of us are cheap
hoes not all of us
take little bits of 60 no some of us are
very high-end some of us are
i need what i'm worth screw conversating
screw debating about it no
it's either gonna give me what i asked
for or you get nothing at all
my time is so valuable i can't have that
back at all
so you're going to pay for my time as
well as your services
you know i'm not just i'm not going to
oh yeah the okie doke 60
here no i can't take that because now i
have two mouths to feed
that's expensive that's very very
expensive plus
you know then it comes along for some
girls it's the pimp
for some of us it's hey there's the baby
daddy that you know he feels like
since you're a hoe i got a i got a baby
mama that's a hoe
she's gonna go get it regardless at the
end of the day she's gonna have money in
her pocket so she'll take care of me
you know some of us have the other big
kids that we have to take care of
including ourselves
we have bills i mean lights gas trash
heating
all that costs life is not free at all
and it's hard when you're only working
in the streets you're
we don't make too much but we do make
you know
most of us put it towards our families
nowadays a lot of the girls are putting
it towards hair and nails
but i for the most part put everything i
can towards my kids
um it's
a cheap job a cheap job it's an easy job
but it's also a risky job
because you put it in your head and
there's thoughts that one day
i might get in that truck with that guy
and because he's got
thousands of dollars in his hand okay
i'm gonna go down to his house he says
his house is over here and we wind up
somewhere completely different
you know now there's the thoughts on i
won't come home
who's gonna take care of my kids um
and it's been a couple of times where
i've
been like [ __ ] what do i do i'm in this
position you know how i'm gonna
get out of this position this time um
i've been hospitalized because
of certain incidents um
like at this moment right now i'm barely
coming out of the situation where i went
to the hospital
i don't remember going um when i woke up
i got the how long were you in a coma
and do you remember being kidnapped um
and i honestly could sit here and say
that i don't remember any of that
i don't even remember barely the day
that i opened my eyes at the hospital
i asked the hospital what happened to me
and
they said you had a major accident
but be happy that you're still alive
you're a survivor
and i ask people all the time like what
happened
and nobody seems to be able to tell me
when i asked the hospital they said we
can't tell you due to hipaa
from my understanding hipaa is like
confidentiality
and it only stands for people if they're
not
the patient so if i'm the patient why
can't you guys tell me why are you using
hip against me
so even until this day i've been out of
the hospital for about six months
i still have no idea what happened to me
so being a prostitute those are the
types of things you get yourself into
it's not like we ask for it but at the
same time it's not like we're trying
to stop it because we still get in the
car because we see money
and money means what bills paid nice
hair nice wigs
nice jewelry you know the attractive
guys
and i'm at the point in life where
i don't want this for myself anymore
because it scares me the thought of not
coming home to my daughters
it scares me to the point where
i i've literally been looking for jobs
every single day
because i don't want that to be the case
where i go home i get dressed and i
leave to go out on this date or go to
the club and work and i don't come home
now my daughters are at the starting
phase the starting point of
what i'm going through of the day
mom's not there now where's the guidance
there's no more guidance
then they're gonna start doing stupid
stuff and i don't want my daughters to
have to live that life whatsoever
because now as an adult i'm mentally and
emotionally broken
and coming back from that type of
lifestyle isn't easy at all
most girls don't well they they kind of
got a saying for it once a whole always
a hoe
can't turn a hole into a housewife but
if the woman really wants to change
then she'll change and i really want to
change
and sometimes for some of us we don't
have the help that we need
we don't have support systems and it
makes it really hard for us
i just lost my kids i was lucky and
fortunate enough for
their grandmother from their dad's side
to um go down to the courts and get them
and it's all due to housing situations
you know being a black woman is very
very hard
because a lot of times people look at us
and they base us off of the last
person's mistakes
we might not get that job that we want
because one they're already intimidated
because we're black in my case
i'm six two and i'm a black woman so
my height is my number two downfall
because now they're
intimidated because i look down on them
and when you have a black woman my size
looking down on you and you're this
itty-bitty little white lady in the
interview you know there's kind of
that shaky vibe going on a lot of times
they don't want to hire
they're afraid that we might steal
something they're afraid
that we might beat somebody up in the
store
you know there's we're stereotyped to
the fullest
and it doesn't matter how good we are
how proper our grammar is
being a black woman a life period is
super hard
we have no choice sometimes but to fall
back on being a prostitute
because of the simple fact that most
people don't want to hire us
they don't give us the chance to be able
to show
what we can do in a workplace it's
instantly oh she's black i'm okay
well her name sounds ghetto so i don't
want her in my store
um she looks like she's gonna steal
something
so prostitution is basically what we're
left with
sometimes we don't have a choice but to
go that route it feels
like we're it's forced on us and i don't
like feeling like things are forced on
me
and i try very very hard i mean i do
construction i'm great at what i do
but at this time i i don't have a choice
but to prostitute because i can't get a
job i've gotten the
oh you're pretty you're a distraction so
we can't hire you
okay well your employee is distracted
over there
i'm doing my job so what does that have
to do with me now i'm being stereotyped
by being a woman and being a black woman
at that it
it's hard and people are not
understanding that they're putting us
all in positions where
you can't be mad when this person runs
off and does this crazy thing over there
downtown because hey look what we're
left with
you're not even giving us a chance to
walk into the interview you're looking
out the window and saying oh she's got
colors to get them okay
you know it's not fair and we can't
teach the younger generations to be any
better than that
if the people we look up to as an adult
aren't doing anything to meet the needs
of us as peoples
and i know that right now there's a lot
everybody's doing bad
everybody is whites blacks mexicans but
we're in a position where we can't get
help from the counties we're not getting
housing
we're not getting anything me and my
daughters were homeless for three or
four months sleeping in my expedition
while their dad was messing around with
this mexican girl
and um lying to me saying that he's at
work
um he's out visiting in redlands with
his dad and no
he's out having vacations and going on
ski trips
and getting married and
lying about all of it swearing how he's
going to be there and how he loves us
and i lost my girls because
i was depending on somebody to be there
that wasn't there
so having a support system is a major
major factor
and most of us don't have that coming
from the gang life the prostitution life
a lot of our
family members dads moms are dead in
jail or drugged out
i mean and even us is the girls that are
working the streets
a lot of us are co-dependent on drugs
mainly i mean we stay up all night
working the streets
i mean we're catching guys that are
coming out of work at 2 30 a.m
you wonder where your husband is hey
he's right here with me you know
it's not a good feeling because we're
not trying to step on anybody's toes but
we need
to be able to feed our families we got
to be able to house ourselves i mean a
hotel room is
86 to 100 or something dollars a night
now we're living day by day off the
little money that we're making
not including our food our housing um
trying to get into
storage units to hold all our stuff
because we do
collect we're good collectors um
all these little expenses add up and
living day by day in a hotel i mean
weekend prices go up about 120 to 150
some hotels want 200 deposits so by the
end of the day
we don't want or we don't put a certain
price in our head because
at the end of the day it adds up you got
a 200 deposit then you got a hundred
dollar room there's 300 right there
now you got food then you've got diapers
and you've got milk then you've got
i mean the expenses just never stop so
we're looking at 1500 to pull in just to
live
the day you know so imagine how hard
we're working
and all that work that we're putting in
so hard for the streets we could be
doing it
in actual store somewhere um trying to
be better
but the prostitution is not going to get
better unless
people are willing to give us the chance
to try
to show them like okay i can do this i'm
people say i'm square no i'm not square
i just have proper grammar
i learned that if you want to get
somewhere in life you have to be able to
present yourself
the way that you should business wise
you know and a lot of these girls are
really ghetto and
and really don't care too much
and if you want to take the opportunity
you have to get the opportunity
to get that you have to look presentable
and you have to be wanted by people
that have got what you need and it's not
saying that you want to use everybody
because i know a lot of these guys at
the end of the day they probably go home
like damn
i wonder what my wife's gonna say um
because we do we talk about it
well we have girl groups to just sit
there like hey wifey i wonder what this
happened what happened over here this
day um
hey what do you think his wife said do
you think your profuse stuck to him like
we talk about the most stupidest [ __ ]
but it's things that matter because
when we sit back i think about it a lot
like damn i just ruined that man's life
he went home and he smells like perfume
and his wife's going to kick him out the
house i think he ruined his own
yeah but you know there could be some
girls don't think about you it's
everybody's choice there's two in that
party so
he said i want to pay for some [ __ ] you
turn around and say hey yeah go pay
oh yeah i'll take your money or you
could be like um
thinking about it like damn i'm hurt
enough so i wouldn't want to hurt
anymore like if
i went home i went back to my room and i
saw my dude laying up with another woman
you know i'm gonna be all brokenhearted
i'm probably gonna throw his ass out
it's nice you have that little sense of
responsibility
you know there's respect levels there's
respect
responsibility loyalty um
i i want longevity that means you have
to be consistent in what you do
and sometimes when you're consistent you
ruin people's lives
and i'm at that point in my life where
i'm at rock bottom
at this moment i think i have like
115 to my name no bank account
i mean i'm i barely have enough money to
to manage a room for a night
my car was just messed up why because
i'm in the hood and i've got all these
guys over here that like me and
i don't like the ass back because
there's nothing
what the [ __ ] do i what am i gonna get
from you literally what what can i gain
from you
you can't give me [ __ ] because you're in
the same place i am stuck in a motel
um so
i don't see anything happening right
there so they're going to get mad and go
busting out car windows and
flattening tires and taking cables
converters and
i'm at the point now where i damn near
don't even have any clothes
why because the prostitution life was
faster and easier and
it just seemed a whole lot better and it
sounded good
especially how she said it the way she
looked it was awesome that was exactly
what i wanted to hear
and that's my best life profession i
want why because she looked good okay
you could go to deities and make a ten
dollar dress look good
i mean dd's and make a ten dollar dress
look good
you know and they don't think about the
downfalls of it like okay now you don't
have any self-respect
other people don't respect you um now
you're putting your life on the line
because you're risking
stds aids syphilis gonorrhea
um you know then now you ain't got no
respect from this lady you can't call
yourself a woman you get all types of
names and
you just wind up not being you anymore
so i'm trying my hardest to get out this
life
it's not easy when you don't have a
support system it's not easy when you
don't have family and especially not
having a father
a king is supposed to teach his princess
you know which way to go what kind
you're you're the spitting image of what
a man in my life needs to be like who
i'm supposed to marry
and if i don't have that then i'm
looking through this looking glass and
i'm like um
i don't know what you're gonna pick
because now it's the this looks
for girls that don't have their dads and
men it turns into the look thing oh his
shoes
his pants how how much were they and
what's he look like this way and what's
he look like that way
and that's when the [ __ ] starts you
start getting into the life like oh man
i picked this guy because he's the image
of what i want turns out to be a gang
member
or a child molester or a pimp or
um a drug addict and it's like dang okay
maybe if my dad was here
and i seen how he treated my mom and i
seen how my mom
you know acted afterwards that would
have gave me a sense on how to get a
good guy
but not having a father i'm like okay
shoot i got i guess i just try them all
how about let's try them all and
my share ain't been the best share
because dad ran away now i'm stuck with
my luggage and my luggage just so
happens to eat
talk walk and poop so
now i've got the expense of three people
and he gets to get off scott diddley
with just him
and it makes it really really hard so i
tell everybody the next dude i [ __ ] with
has to be
knowledge knowledge person once you mind
[ __ ] woman with knowledge that is the
best [ __ ] she will ever have
and you will have her all the way and
that's why a lot of these girls
are like stuck in the life because they
think that the guy that they're talking
to is so knowledgeable and he's smart
and he's this and he's that one really
it's not
most of that is just the gift of gabbing
i tell him he's
academy's best award-winning actor
because uh
you're not fooling anybody a lot of
women right now are renegades
because the men are very
what's the word i'm looking for they
don't know how to communicate
they lack an attention to the women that
they're
working they don't want to do [ __ ] but
buy
clothes and shoes and drugs and sit
there in the same position
like we'll work really hard for you to
still have us in the same position
why why are you doing this why can't you
just like go put me in a house
you spent 1500 on a bracelet but you
won't spend 1500 on a house
that's not okay with me i'd rather be
out of the life
but i need somebody to give me the
chance you know
to show them like i have the potential
to do something else
i don't want to be looked at like hey
that's that girl that was working on the
corner over there
that's embarrassing a lot of days i go
out with certain people i don't even get
out the car
i won't i won't get out the car because
i'm like oh damn
oh one out of this one other certain
selected few of 50 people seen me
walking down that blade
two out of this certain hundred people
have had a date with me
you know and i got bodies
that's what we call we call them bodies
because when you have
guys dates tricks whatever you want to
call them they tally up
so we call them bodies i got bodies and
i'm not trying to be that speedometer
like wow you're up there in the
accounting i don't want to be the car
that somebody's like okay
this car caught 200 000 miles on i have
no need for it anymore
i want to be that one that's like okay i
could go out with him
and i could actually get out the car and
go in the store because you guys haven't
seen me with all these guys
his friends can't be like hey yeah i
[ __ ] her already and oh it's that good
or is that trash
you know we get talked about and i don't
want to be that girl i want to be the
girl that's respected and married and
loved and cherished for the rest of her
life and
you know eventually a business owner
somebody the kids can look up to
if we want to change somebody has to
make the start somewhere
and that means putting your foot forward
and trying
at least and me in the position that i'm
i'm in i don't even know where i'm
supposed to be starting at honestly
i don't i mean i've been stolen from my
even now the edd people are just
continuously taking taking taking
i ain't got nothing left to take the
only thing left to take for me is my
life
when you get to thinking like that it's
it's not too good and people
don't care most people money really
don't care
because it's not them and it's not their
life it's not their kids so why give a
[ __ ]
um and then they get to feel bad
afterwards
i express people a lot because you might
have been the person to save that
person's life
if i come to you and i say look i need
five thousand dollars hey look help me
get this car so i can get to work
hey look i need this um i'm short for my
rent the babies have no diapers
sometimes people need somebody to be
able to come to an asset to that
ain't gonna judge them and that will
actually help because some of us do want
to do better
but in their heads all nah they gonna go
get some weed
they're gonna go party they're gonna go
drink
and because last person ruined that
because that's what they did we get
judged off that
you can't judge this person off the last
person's mistakes
because you can either be the reason
i turned around and i wrote this letter
and i killed myself because hey
i couldn't even get god to help me you
know i couldn't get this one person
how is this person so rich and they
don't even want to help me with 500
they can't help me with a bucket from a
an auction
so i can at least try to get to my kids
so i at least try to get to this job
oh well that shows how much people
actually care so why not what am i here
for
then now there's no more me and you get
to have that burden like damn
if i would only help this person you
know
they might still be here they might not
have been the happiest person but they
were always smiling
like me a lot of people are like megan
you're always happy you're always
smiling i'm like no
i'm i'm not i'm not always happy and i'm
not always smiling
but when i come outside i try to smile
because i don't want to ruin somebody
else's day because
what i'm going through but my every day
is hell
my everyday is thinking the same damn
thing
what if i never get to see my kids again
why won't anybody help when we're truly
needing it
people want to be judgmental but
don't know what our lives are like on a
day-to-day basis
you could be the most beautiful woman
and still feel
so unpretty and in my case that's
exactly what it is
people tell me every day how pretty i am
i am and i i don't see it because
the life that i have to live and the
simple fact
of not having a support system neither
parents
none of my brothers and sisters talk to
me because i'm black and they're white
i'm you people is what they say
we can't help you people i'm like wow
you really sit here and talk to me like
that and i'm your little sister
what do you mean you people or
you know not having friends sometimes
people just don't trust you because
you're black
and not having that help and not having
a vehicle not having an apartment has
put me in a position where
i am two months away of almost losing my
kids for adoption
because i don't have the means to be
able to get
a solid foundation a living situation
um the lord knows i would go to
war with god for my kids
so are drugs a part of your life um they
are um
it just depends on like where my mindset
is at the time
most of the girls do it so that they
stay up because we do work very late
nights sometimes we work from
shoe we might go out at eight o'clock at
night and we don't get back in until
12 o'clock the next day because why
daddy said you have to have this much
money when you come home
and if daddy don't get his money then
you're gonna get your ass whooped
and we all know we don't want to ask for
it but when we get home
so we're going to stay out and do it we
have to it don't matter if we got to
walk into the restaurant and tell them
the cook in the back like hey you on a
date so crystal meth is
your drug yeah and you're still working
you're still giving your money to
somebody
um no i put all my money in my pocket
because i really feel like if i'm gonna
pay you
you have had to did something and these
guys don't do [ __ ] but sit there and
talk to the homie that's in the
passenger side dick riding
and if you over there dick writing you
smoking my money with him text me that's
what you call it he's smoking your weed
so
you smoking my weed with your homie
that's broke as [ __ ] in the passenger
side not doing nothing being a pretend
pimp
i feel some type of way because you
wouldn't do [ __ ] to to get that money
you know i need my weed after this
because now i'm stressed out you talk
like a girl from the street
yeah i could tell i i i choose to be
proper
because it gets you a little bit further
in life yes it will and
a lot of these girls they they just
don't want to learn that's probably
the very smart women the women that i
see out here are [ __ ]
intelligent as hell and i look at some
of it i'm like god damn you have so much
[ __ ] potential what the [ __ ] are you
doing out here they're doing the same
thing that i'm doing out here trying to
make a way to live
not all of us are dumb not all of us are
street
completely like most of us are very very
smart
most of us could probably be in harvard
these women that are out here
are beautiful not all of us are young
but they're beautiful women
with great minds great mentalities great
ideas
that nobody wants to hear because we're
just your average black girl from the
hood
which is a [ __ ] up way to say it but
we're not looked at like how white women
are looked at
you know we don't get the same respect
as they do because we're from the hood
people are scared of the hood i mean
people i know people that won't even
drive
through the areas i have to go through
because they're afraid they might get
robbed or something
i mean i go in a store and the lady's
like clutch let me get my purse and hold
it
tight as i can it's like lady just cause
you seen a black person you don't have
to hold your
we're not gonna hurt you
you know it's really hard being a black
woman but it's
i think it puts us above strong
because it's hard and we do things that
the guys have to do
so being a black woman
and having to be the boss the head thing
i get to be the head fit today you know
baby daddy's not the round i'm the
hippie i'm the boss what emotion do you
get
you know the most depression or
most of the time is depression because
within ourselves we no longer feel
secure we no longer feel beautiful
we no longer feel like we're lovable
because we slept with so many men or
because we've done this with so many
different people that
you know other religions other races
they look at it like
you do that then you're a [ __ ] you're
you're a prostitute regardless of what
the
religious or the whatever but it's got
to break your psyche after a while
yeah your self-worth has to get beaten
down yeah it
it beats you further than down i mean
we're below sea level we're drunk
we drown then we hit rock bottom and it
keeps going and then the drug use
kind of exacerbates it and you see why
there's a lot of women that are
drugged out well it would be hard to do
this if you weren't high
yeah i mean we get the cases of guys
that just don't take care of themselves
bodily wise um hygiene is off
we get the guys that are very aggressive
we get guys that want to kidnap you we
get guys that are just the best that
we've ever met in life but you're
married so i can't have you
you know um and it does it takes a major
toll on you
every day the same thing for i mean just
imagine we've got girls that have been
doing it for the last 50 years
still you know they're old as hell but
they look good because black don't crack
you know this lady can look as good as
she want to be but how many people do
you think she slept with she's a
prostitute
you can't really expect the certain
expectations we've met
if in your head you know she's a
prostitute and that [ __ ]
takes a major toll a major major toll i
mean
if if you were me you sat back and
thought about it like
damn yesterday i went on a date with 23
people
you look damn that's nasty as [ __ ] 23
people that's horrible
you know and from the outside looking
it's like uh
[ __ ] you up here sleeping with any and
everybody and you don't want to be
looked at like that so the first thing
that hits you is damn people are looking
at me this way my image is [ __ ] up
then damn my parents might have seen me
down there on the blade
damn i went on that date and he didn't
even pay for it he stole my money
like he went through my purse and took
my [ __ ] and he left
there's cases where you just like [ __ ]
man i just lost my whole
week's worth of work because i got in
the shower while he was still there
and then you get to get beat up when you
go home because now you ain't got no
money to show for
and you had more money than all the
girls he got this today
i might have had 2500. this [ __ ] just
stole everything i had
i'd agreed and it's like damn now he
used to go home in that bs silverado
truck
go inside to homecook meal and i got to
go back out to that street and make more
money just like get a hotel
that's not including food just the hotel
i don't get to eat till tomorrow
you know it's hard and then the kids
when you think about it like damn here
comes the depression crawling up my leg
kick my ass
and it a lot of days
i don't want to wake up i'll be honest a
lot of days i don't want to wake up
because the thought that placed in my
head is damn
here's another [ __ ] day without a job
without any [ __ ] help i don't
have somebody to call to talk to about
the situation that i'm in
you know my phone bills do where the
hell am i going to get my phone bill
money from that's just 60
so if i'm getting depressed and crying
over 60
just imagine how having to do this every
single day
will get to you like damn i already
don't have no self-respect
i can't get a guy in my life depending
on it because they all know me as a
prostitute
nobody wants to be with the press too
because why she slept with the whole
town
but we don't really have a choice so
what does that leave us
at
that's my main thing is this your lowest
point
yeah this has been my lowest point and
it's
quite frankly it's not fun i mean i can
be as pretty as i want to be but
pretty ain't paying the bills i mean
pretty can pay the bills if you go
outside and you work for it
but pretty's not paying the bills and
it's hard
right now it's like the thoughts of i
might not ever see my babies again
um the thoughts that
hey i'm never gonna be able to settle
down or be loved by anybody because what
i have to do now
and that's a [ __ ] feeling to have
nobody should have to feel like
that at all
can i smoke this one
what's the most important lesson you've
learned
the most important lesson that i've
learned is
never give up on yourself because when
you give up on yourself you're ready to
do
and willing to do anything just for a
couple of dollars
when technically to be honest those
dollars don't mean [ __ ] because we have
nothing behind our currency there's no
gold there's no diamonds there's nothing
so technically we're working for
something that was just reprinted
we're working for a piece of paper
regular piece of paper
we're not working for anything
technically we're working just to be
judged even more than we're already
judged
i mean it's not getting us into
apartments not giving us a car at least
you know a lot of us
think of it this way if we had a car at
least we could sleep in it
you know we'd have some type of security
that'll just the first step of getting a
little bit further than we are today
oh i got me a little bucket a little
lemon card from a lot
you know that's putting us a step above
and it makes us that's what makes us
feel better is knowing okay
i called my friend and he said you know
what i want to see you get your kids
back here it goes five hundred dollars
i'm gonna take you to the auction you go
get you a car okay there was that first
little spark of enjoyment the first sign
that hey
you know i feel a little bit better i
might actually go apply for a job today
you know and i don't have that so
a lot of the girls do actually come from
good homes
they just don't want to be there they
don't like authority
and then there's the girls like me that
have no family no friends
um everybody wants to hate me because
i'm pretty when i'm like hey look
i'm average just like you i don't put
myself on a pedestal
i'm down to earth i'm not your everyday
pretty girl
most girls you meet look like me are
like oh my god
i'm so much better than you and they're
like way up here on this pedestal
i'm like hey lady come here come here
let me tell you something get off the
pedestal
we both bleed the same blood so i'm not
better than you
and people see oh she's pretty she
probably got everything people think i'm
rich for some odd reason people think
like i'm some rich high-end
escort or something i'm like no bro no
i stay in a hotel over there all fig how
rich can you possibly be staying on fake
oh you you've got money meg you've got
you've got you know my street name is
megan
when you go out you don't want to tell
these guys your real name so you give
them fake names
oh you're rich you pretend to be broke
so you can have some friends like no
i'm not i'm not rich but in order to get
the dates that we want the good money
you got to pay for the good hair and the
good makeup and the good everything and
they get stolen from you because that
prostitute came in and then she left
you know they call it pay and pipping
choosing a lot of these hoes chews up
chews up chews up they're constantly in
this little
washing machine where they get thrown
around the same guys
so there's either i kill myself or
you're washed up and dragged out
and eventually most of the time it goes
to being drugged out
because the girls can't stay up at night
time
are you are you secretly hoping that
some prince charming some richard gere
comes along and and
saves you from this yes a lot of the
girls have told me they are
secretly hoping yeah expecting no
because
i mean come on prince charming just
rolls up out of nowhere into the hood
like hey girl come on
i'll take you with me i'll get you out
this life not going to happen
i don't get my hopes too high even if
even if it did would you be able to
able to accept it in the mental state
you're in now
uh you know that's a great question
because
i asked myself that a lot like dan what
would happen if you did get somebody
that wanted to see you do better
somebody want to give you the chance in
hell that you've been looking for
and i'm like damn well i don't want to
ruin anybody because
i'm ruined like i'm broken so if i go
with this person it might just room so
i've had it happen once or twice where
there is a good guy that wants to talk
to me he's like i don't care i'll help
you until you get back on your feet i'm
just like
i run from it i don't know about other
women i can only speak for myself but i
run from it
that's right because i don't want to
break you because i'm broken and they're
like well what do you mean i don't
understand
i just feel like you don't like me you
know it's not that i don't like you it's
that
i don't want to ruin the person that you
are when you're a great man
because of what i'm going through now if
you're willing to stick by me with all
these
you know up and down emotions the the
court case and
for the kids and the crazy baby daddy
pimp and
if you're good with that be my guest
but i would really rather just try to
get me together than
possibly ruining somebody that's
fantastic for somebody else
hey it might not be for me it might be
for the next lady
but i don't want to be the one that
ruined him or
hey he left me for the prostitute [ __ ]
i don't i don't want to carry those
types of titles i want somebody to be
with me because that's what they truly
want
want you know and it's a rarity to find
a prince charming that's like hey i want
you
and all of you so most of the time these
prince charmings are like hey yeah
i want you and all of you but only for
tonight you know they make it sound to
the point where okay this is what i got
i i need it and you go do that with him
and then boom
you're calling him the next day his
phone number's changed or
come find out it's text free and his
brother owns the business and not him
you know i don't really want to take
those chances so i try not to put my
feelings in any of this anymore
um but it would be a great feel to
actually get married and settle down and
say love that you actually can love the
person and not love
their pocket or be scared of them
in my case i'm i kind of scared of my
kid's dad
and being a pimp he was very aggressive
he's not in the life anymore but
i'm the woman and right now the women
seem to be the ones doing everything so
i always find myself getting up like
okay i'm gonna make ends meet somehow
some way
i'ma get it somehow some way
and i always make it happen i might not
feel the best at the end of the day
sometimes you might catch me like uh
[ __ ] get the hell out of my face i'm uh
don't don't talk to me just don't talk
to me
what's wrong with her [ __ ] the [ __ ]
went outside and she made the money that
she needed today but she wasn't treated
like a person
never is there a day that we're treated
like real humans we're treated like
trash we're talked to like trash
and just because we're prostitutes
doesn't mean that we should be treated
any
worse than any other person i'm not
better
than anybody but i do think that
prostitutes do deserve the chance to be
able
to be treated like a human still be told
that they're beautiful
you know still looked at like a regular
person
and we get looked at with the most
nastiest looks
but if you were to step back and think
about it like damn
these girls have no help whatsoever
they're women so our vulnerability is at
a high
a high point you know and guys take
advantage of that
they see that okay she's homeless and
she's got her kids by herself i'm gonna
take advantage
because they know our mind state's not
at the best
and i'm tired of being taken advantage
of i'm tired of being used i'm tired of
having to sell myself because for all
these people now i might just want to
save me for one guy
and you think because what i do to make
ends meet to make sure my children are
fed
that i love being a prostitute oh that
girls love being out there no we don't
who wants to be cold at three o'clock in
the morning standing on a freaking
corner in high heels
nobody nobody at all nobody that i've
met at least
and we're judged so much that it's like
damn
why should i care why should i give a
[ __ ]
and then that's when the oh that that
black woman was so rude to me and she
makes me so scared a lot of these women
are scared of us because
we just look forward [ __ ] i'm tired of
you talking about me
like okay i'm not fed off a silver spoon
my family didn't hand me down nothing
i don't got five cars and all them just
sit there and don't get driven they just
sit there and gather dust no i don't
have those royalties
i came from the hood where my mom is you
know in the penitentiary my dad got shot
and died and my brothers don't give a
[ __ ] they're all pimps
i come from that type of lifestyle and
we don't have the royalties that most
people have
so when you're fed off a silver spoon
you think completely different
way different and you wouldn't think the
thought of
hey maybe i should put myself in their
shoes
maybe i should just think about what i
would be doing if i had to live their
life
or maybe i should step back and
reanalyze
what i'm about to say because this
woman's a black woman she's a prostitute
i think that would be the start of a
change
is these women because honestly quite
frankly
a lot of us people think the white and
the black no a lot of us look up to a
lot of these white women
like sandra bullock i love her oh my god
she's great
um a lot of us look up to these ladies
and
even though we're prostitutes and we're
black
we're still young and we look up to
those older women
the same women they're like i won't help
you because you're black i won't help
you because you're a prostitute
we look up to the same people and we
actually look up to them
we look at them to see where their
wisdom is
new new um sayings new quotes another
way of thinking
because they're our older generation
regardless of what color they are
they're the ones teaching us so if you
taught me this i'm teaching them that
kids are like sponges they absorb they
install they intake and they reuse it
so when it comes time to reuse if all
they're hearing is [ __ ] [ __ ] you i'm
gonna slap your mama
gang bang slap a [ __ ] you know then
they're gonna be
grown gang bang slap a [ __ ] and it's
just gonna keep like a recycling thing
but if one of us can be like hey you
know what i want to change this
how about i talk a little bit more
proper how about
instead of being a prostitute that's got
holes everywhere and you can see my my
[ __ ] and my
my nipples how about i go out there a
little more covered
than the last girl you got to try to
start it somewhere try to respect
yourself
that's why i kind of dress a little bit
more closed in
and then you gotta think about it you do
get a little bit more money because i
see what you got now what she got over
there because she's got clothes on
you know everybody's different
but when it comes to the prostitution
game we're kind of all one and one
we're all the same we all want better
but we're not getting anymore
i mean [ __ ] they don't even have program
specialized
for for prostitutes there's not a lot
actually now that i think about it that
helps the girls get out the life people
want us out the life but they're not
helping us
we want out the life i mean we cry most
of us
are emotional depressed wise because
we don't have [ __ ] for our families we
can't get a job because we're black
she might as i can't get a job because
i'm black and i'm six too i'm bigger
than half the guys that i'm asking for a
job
it's hard and we all want a chance
and if i get somebody to help me with
that chance or somebody at least say
that i believe in you
that would be a great start for me
because i don't have a support system
period
i have me and my daughters we are sam
sayora aurora
and me sam the definition of together
and i will go to war with god for them
and i can't lose them
i won't lose them so that means if i got
to get out there and
work every man in the united states i
will do that
because at least i can say that i have
my kids
and that's the only place that i'm
getting love from
i don't have dad i don't have mom i kind
of mind my business it's me myself and i
and that makes it even more hard
so all right david thank you so much for
sharing your story
i got a feeling well we'll do this more
than once
because you have a lot on your chest
don't you
i have a i got how to say i got issues
no i'd love to do this more than once
and i'll help you out at least make your
week a little bit easier oh
you